what's up crap stuff hey what's up good
man I feel like we need we need a better
name for you man you don't be known as
the crap stuff guy that's the name
actually came from I was supposed to
start a YouTube channel and start to
make prank videos okay
oh that comment kind of starts from
there you know all right how can I help
me what's up I actually saw your video
about don't follow your passion I was so
confused by the video because I 50% of
my brain was actually I was like
thinking in the same way as you do like
don't follow your passion and the 50%
was like thinking that I should follow
my passion so I read a book called
so good they can't ignore you by call
Newport after reading that book I
actually changed my mind totally because
whenever I get some some kind of advice
from people who say is just follow
passion that kind of confused me and I
could that after reading that book I
totally changed my mind to not following
my passion because the idea of being
following my passion is like I want to
be a soccer player and I want to be a
basketball player I want to be a doctor
and things like that you know like the
hard things to do in life okay and most
people like they're like not everyone
can be a basketball player not everyone
can be Ronaldo or not everyone can be
doctors you know I just wanted to ask
you if you have somehow change your mind
after I throw in that that video on them
on YouTube on like do you still believe
that you should follow your passion or
Geo's yeah you have you have like
changed your mind to to the to the
opposite side where you instead of
believing in Folio passing maybe you
have changed your mind in in not
following your passion instead of work
category and from there you explore your
ideas and find your path yeah so listen
I haven't seen
my cents if anything I've doubled down
even harder on it if you i've studies
success it's what I do right you look at
any of the videos on my channel we've
only grown in the number of people we've
profiled and the number one thing that
comes back consistently is they're doing
whether you call a fellow your passion
do the thing that you love follow your
bliss follow your curiosity like there's
a lot of ways to say it
everybody everybody at the top says that
show me one person who has one one hard
not like become a middle manager
somewhere but like is that the top of
their game and didn't absolutely love
the work that they're doing
the thing is so yeah like you may not be
able to be a soccer player right but if
that's your love you could still be in
the world of like maybe you're a soccer
coach or maybe you're a soccer manager
or maybe you you know create
motivational content for soccer players
like if you love soccer you can still
have success in the world of without
being the best player itself or maybe
you love prank videos and just like go
be the best prank video person but
here's the thing if you don't love prank
videos if you don't love prank videos
you will get crushed you can get some
success but you will never be at the top
if you don't love what you're doing look
at everybody like who do you who do you
think is the greatest at what they do
look at Ronaldo tell me he doesn't love
soccer look at whatever athlete whatever
entrepreneur whatever musician whatever
artist and tell me that they don't
absolutely love the craft that they're
doing this is a message that comes up
consider honestly think you're
misinterpreting what Cal is saying
because the people who are at the top
they love what they're doing so you can
have success grinding something out in a
field that you don't like but you're
never going to be the best because the
people who love what they do will beat
you why did you give up on crap stuff
why did you go up and prank videos in
the beginning I was just thinking like
okay the pranking concept it should be
fun for the the viewers like the people
watching it and the people who get hit
who gets a good sprain yeah and the
person who is who is performing the act
right I was thinking like that everybody
should enjoy it but I quickly realized
that I'm not the person who will be
enjoying
the pranking thing oh so you don't love
it no I don't for happen to following
your passion this is exactly what you're
doing you're not following your passion
great I say great like I saw your video
and I was like okay I totally agree with
with Evan Carmichael and after I was I
was reading that book I was like hold on
a second I also also agree what would
they call Newport it depends man if I
thought was like 10 years old and I
would follow my passion to prank videos
that would fit me much more than I do at
the age of 28
sure and you need to adjust your what
you get excited about may change it may
adjust here's what I think the people
who love making prank videos they will
always beat you because they love it
because they love they love they stay up
at night thinking about it because they
they have the fire for where you could
think about it but you don't enjoy doing
it and the best thing for you to do is
not force yourself to do prank videos
for the next 25 years of your life but
to move on to something that you
actually enjoy the process the people
who win enjoy the process more than the
results don't you think that the love
also what would automatically
automatically come in if you like decide
to work hard in a specific category so
then do have a great video do it do it
then do it do it for your prank videos
the love will come and the love will
come and let the love come do your prank
videos forever yeah thank you so much
no but like so what are you gonna do
yeah I want you to I want you to find
clarity man I don't want you to leave
here even more confused than when you
came in I'll probably go because for the
past 3 to 3 months my younger brother
has also been in the same category he
wants to like go out and prank people so
I'll probably like start to go back to
the pranking and just see just see if
like if I can figure out dude you're
killing me you're gonna go back to the
pranking videos even though you know you
don't like the pranking videos yeah but
I'm just thinking like maybe I can give
a second chance to I'm since I'm in the
middle of of
a person who is giving me the advice to
follow my passion and a person that the
author who's who's telling me to go and
work hard so if I can put that the bow
Tobias is together and just go and do
something and do this something which I
really have tried of course and let's
see if the craft my idea weights more RF
it's the father look follow your passion
my idea waits more you you know you know
what I'm trying to say yeah you got to
combine both you got to follow your
passion and work hard it's not one or
the other it's not just follow your
passion and sit on the couch daydreaming
about being a pilot it's being out there
actually working on that's what allows
you to be so good look at any of your
heroes in whatever accomplishments
they've had any field and show me one
person who does not love what they're
doing
confine it so then your best is just to
be the next level down you can still
have success you could have success
doing prank videos for some time
eventually the people will crush you who
love it and you will just grow to hate
your life like waking up every day and
going to do something that you hate more
and more and more that can lead you to
monetary success it's just not a life
that feels right like why why not wake
up and do something that you love like
if you love soccer so much but you're
gonna be too old to keep going with
soccer what can you do is anything
interesting in the world of soccer like
do you want to be a soccer coach you
want to be a soccer trainer do wanna be
a soccer analyst you want to be a soccer
videogame designer like what can you do
is there anything interesting in the
world of soccer besides being on the
pitch plane that's interesting for you I
also read a book called the blue ocean
strategy yeah and that that tells you
more or less to like not doing something
that majority people of all people are
already doing and yeah also it's kind of
confuses me because like I was like okay
I want you know for pranks but when you
just go into YouTube and search for just
one word prank you will probably get 1
million views or 1 million 1 million
results this is so important that this
is tying everything together this is
really poor
okay listen this is I hope this really
helps you there is always room for
quality at the top if you're the best at
something you will always win you could
say that being a soccer player like how
many people in the world want to be a
soccer player tons but if you're really
really good at it you can win now in the
world of soccer it's really defined but
in the world of business you can win in
so many different ways and it's a
lifetime thing like you could be 65
years old still crushing it as an
entrepreneur Plus and so how you
ultimately end up winning is by being
yourself not by copying somebody else
yeah and you you be yourself by bringing
your passion to the work that you're
doing what am i doing an Instagram right
now when I came when I went on YouTube
I was I was nothing there were already
lots of big youtubers and I built it up
from from 7000 subscribers to 1.3
million in four years and now I'm doing
the same thing on Instagram I started
from nothing I still have nothing in
comparison and I'm putting in the work
I'm being me I'm not gonna do it by
copying whoever is big on Instagram and
trying to do the exact same thing as
them I'm bringing believe I'm bringing
my brand I'm doing four times a week on
IG live I want to help people one on one
I'm bringing what I do I will never win
trying to be a junior you know Steve
Jobs who's on my wall there and I can
have some success trying to copy just
what he's done but if I want to
ultimately win if I want to be the best
then I have to be me I've got to tap
into things that I love doing that's the
blue ocean strategy so it doesn't mean
that you can't win in a complicated
market right it's not that you can't win
on YouTube it's not that you can't win
on Instagram and you have to go to some
tiny little social network that nobody
knows about to win you can win but you
win by being you you wouldn't by
bringing something different and the
difference is just a thing that only you
can bring so you got to figure out what
that is
so what is it I don't have that's all
right okay but but like I want to align
your thinking to the right thing all
right starting to not about any specific
topic but like about everything that
comes in in my life like soccer weather
European
a lifestyle healthy lifestyle workout
gym okay so let me ask you something are
you are you yeah are you in a
relationship you have a girlfriend are
married or husband or whatever in a
relationship right no okay but you've
had you've had relationships in the past
yes okay so so here's what you're
talking about you're saying I'm gonna
get an arranged marriage and I will
learn to love this person right that's
what you're saying
start start a business and you will
learn to love it so being an arranged
marriage and I will learn to love this
woman for the rest of my life I'll have
to learn to do it but don't you think
like if I start to focus on one topic
that will definitely limit my amount of
content I'm not seeing focus on one
topic if you want to do more do more I
love it
who said pick one topic I'm picking I
want to pick what what I care about look
at my youtube channel I do top tens I do
n spresso they do seven ways I do these
live streams it's all around believing
in entrepreneurs but how I do it
changes a lot you don't the only write
about travel I think if you only write
about travel or only write about soccer
unless that's the thing that just makes
you come alive then I think you lose but
that idea of getting to a business and
eventually you're going to love it is is
the arranged marriage and listen some
people they have great arranged
marriages and they make it work to me
that concept is crazy
I would rather date a couple people all
right or as many dates as it takes
to figure out who I want to marry yeah
so if you don't know who you want to
marry then what do you do you go on a
bunch of dates if you don't know what
you want to do then what do you do you
try a whole bunch of stuff yeah but just
like a first date the answer then is
well do I want to have a second date
with them you don't have to think do I
want to marry this person right away
it's do I want to go back for a second
date and then you get to know them you
get to like them and then you might lead
to marriage it's the same thing for a
business you try something you try the
pranks I don't like it great I don't
want to do
you try a blog maybe you like it for six
months and you drop it you need to what
you need to do is rapidly test lots of
different things need to go on lots of
dates yeah try it as many things as
possible until you find the thing that
that was really cool like I want to do
that again and then you do it again
I need to keep doing that and it might
be the thing that you fall in love with
and you do for the rest of your life or
it might be a six-month window or a
six-year window or a 60 year window you
don't know but you will not figure it
out by sitting on the couch ding human
about it you got to go out and start
doing so I think you should be doing
more like you started a blog awesome I
love it great if you have no idea of the
blogs in a workout or something else
that you want to do then then the next
year of your life you're off spending
saying yes to a whole bunch of different
things until you find the thing that you
want to go back to I think you lose in
in the prank Channel yeah and and what I
would do is just imagine the next 30
years of your life doing prank videos is
that a happy life for you and the long
run though great so let's figure out
what you can write like to start finding
the thing now that can lead to the law
because I don't think you're even happy
in the short run I think you'll deal
with it you'll tolerate it but it's not
what you want to do so you either learn
how to get really really good at
something that you hate or learn to get
good that's something that you love like
what sounds like a better strategy for
life right and that may mean you're not
gonna be a soccer player great but
there's lots of other things that you
could love too and all I'm encouraging
to do is to test the waters and try and
explore those things instead of forcing
yourself and locking yourself in a path
because that's what most people do most
people pick a job because it's safe or
because their parents did it and then
they end up waking up and driving to a
job that they hate for the rest of their
lives and they're too afraid to bounce
off and go do something else
I want you to win man thanks man put on
the calendar for the next three months I
want you to try 25 different things
spending today 25 different things you
want to go and do the vlogging or the
not the vlogging that prank with your
brother
great spend a half day doing that I
think here you know you're not gonna
like it but whatever do it again just
just to prove to yourself and then
24 other things that are brand-new that
you've never done before
just a taste this is see if it gets you
going and excited or you hate it got 45
different things 25 different things
expect to suck at all of them yeah
expect to have no natural talent or
skill at all them don't worry about did
you get a great result like gold so go
salsa dancing you might be terrible at
salsa dancing you will be the first time
you try it but the only thing that you
want to pay attention to is did you
enjoy the process did you enjoy learning
those dance steps
did you enjoy jumping from that plane
did you enjoy taking that cooking class
and do you want to go back and do it
again yeah if you try 25 different
things you'll likely find one or two
that actually want to stick with and
that may surprise you even if you want
to put it up on your on your Facebook or
your IG like hey I'm looking for 25
things what do you guys suggest and then
take the first 25 and go do those things
that's cool yeah
just that journey will be an inspiration
to people who are who are watching you
because most people are too afraid to do
that you're saying I don't know what I
want to do I'm trying to figure it out
and the way to figure it out is to try a
whole bunch of things and reading books
and watching videos helps but you won't
know until you do it so you've got to go
and try and do it and listen worst case
if at all if my advice sucks right yeah
then then at the end of day you've tried
25 different things and that's something
to be proud of
yeah they'll think you're an inspiration
yeah out of 25 things I try I definitely
should at least like two or three of
them right that's the start man that's a
third over them but don't delay like in
the next three months you got to do
twenty-five different things absolutely
man
cool good luck man thank you so much
calling in if you tell yourself a story
long enough you start to believe it
don't you believe it you act like I am
Tulsa what a whale out of handcuffed
lightning both London
now you know I'm bad all the last week I
murdered a rock into the stone
hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make
medicine sick the fundamental key to
success is it can take between 18 and
254 days of taking action for a new
habit to stick I've created a new course
called 254 confidence or every single
day for 254 days I will be sending you a
video between 30 seconds and 5 minutes
long that you start your morning with
around making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access